[Applause]  [Music]  okay I'm out then show me okay  yes there it is the room is yours they  are lucky to be in your presence now the  turn yes you are tiny God let's show him  up  it might get weird I'll be there ASAP  Disney Pixar's Incredibles 2 comes to  digital in blu-ray he said a new job  doing hero work so things haven't  spiraled up control the moment I left  I've got this everything's great why  would they change math math when you  bring it home you'll get auntie Edna an  exclusive all GU short featuring Jack  Jack now the ten yes you are tiny God  please  Pixar's Incredibles to get it on digital  October 23rd bring it home on blu-ray  November 6 also new on 4k Ultra HD  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]